the jurgen experience and so i think the
supply chain issue is is is is a big
part of this and the assessment of
vulnerabilities and you know we're in a
race because it takes you it takes like
five six years to develop a fab you know
to generate semiconductors there are big
investments happening now in in phoenix
you know for example phoenix is is going
to be the site of a of an a um you know
a tsmc uh uh big fab tsmc is the is the
chip manufacturer that's based in taiwan
right which is you know a single point
of failure almost you know for big parts
of our supply chain internationally and
of course the reason that's significant
is it's an it's in a it's in a place
that's under threat by the china's
commerce party as well yeah i think
they're making a samsung plant a chip
plant here in texas as well they are
they are yeah right and in austin it's
outside of austin yeah that's uh it's
just terrifying to think that we have to
catch up in six years
because six years in the world of tech
is that's uh a hundred years it's an eon
it is but there's there's a lot you can
do even before that and i think it's
starting to happen in terms of the
shifting of supply chains elsewhere you
just saw intel is going to invest a lot
in malaysia you might think well why in
malaysia well i think the key is it
doesn't all have to be in the united
states
it has to be in a number of places so
it's resilient right if what if there's
a natural disaster a power added outage
right you want multiple sources and and
of course you know as you mentioned the
reason this became apparent to all of us
was at the beginning of it right when
you couldn't get ppe and pharmaceuticals
and and so forth so i think you know i
think we're just waking up to this
competition
and this ought to be one of those areas
where we all come together right this
should not be a partisan
issue at all and it should be a
multinational issue right the the reason
the subtitle of the book is the fight to
defend the free world is we need others
to come with us right yeah we need the
european union and the uk and japan and
australia i think that's starting to
happen as well right because
you know
look at what xi jinping has done just
since the pandemic right
foisted the pandemic on the world
yo crushed anybody who was trying to
ring the alarm bells about it these are
reporters and and doctors right then
added insult to injury with this wolf
warrior diplomacy which i know you've
talked about on the show here as well
uh and then and then a range of
aggressive actions like you know
bludgeoning indian soldiers to death on
the himalayan frontier right scores of
overflights into into taiwanese air
defense identification zone
weaponizing islands in the south china
sea and if they if they succeed there
will be the largest land grab so to
speak in history and that's you know by
the way an area across which one third
of the world's surface trade flows right
you know the intimidation towards japan
a massive campaign of economic coercion
against australia and now lithuania and
so what i would often hear you know from
friends you know in in southeast asia
and beyond you know these are my
counterparts when uh who are engaging
when i was a national school advisor
they would say don't don't force us to
choose right don't force it to choose
between washington and beijing
and what i what i would tell them is hey
that's not the choice you face right the
choice you face is between sovereignty
and servitude right and you know the
united states is on the side of
sovereignty
china wants servitude because what xi
jinping wants to do
and the party's clear about this is they
want to establish exclusionary areas of
primacy across the indo-pacific region
and excluding who us right as the first
step in and really being able to rewrite
some of the rules of international
commerce and political discourse and and
then to isolate their their regional
rival japan right and so i i think it's
we're at a critical moment where we have
to compete effectively and this is not
this does not mean that we have to we're
on a path to confrontation actually i
think joe because we had
vacated these competitive spaces china
became more and more emboldened and we
were actually on a path to confrontation
when now i think this idea of
transparent competition is is what we
ought to really pursue with china so do
do you think that that makes us less
likely to be in competition with china
in terms or less likely to be in
conflict with china if we can change our
whole uh economic profile here in terms
of tech in terms of manufacturing i do i
do because i think really we have to
recognize what china's trying to do
right so people people talk about
decoupling all the time and you allude
to this a little bit like hey you know
businesses have to make a decision right
i mean they they've got responsibilities
to their shareholders they've you know
and and so forth
so the whole idea of a complete
decoupling that's always been kind of
like a red herring right that's not what
we're talking about i mean what we ought
to do is is ask businesses
take a hippocratic oath right don't do
any hurt or harm in three areas
first of all
don't help the chinese communist party
gain an unfair differential advantage
over us
militarily or in the emerging
data-driven you know uh global economy
second right i mean don't help the party
you know don't don't help the party uh
perfect it's technologically enabled
orwellian police state right don't help
them do that don't invest in chinese ai
companies right that are extinguishing
human freedom and weaponizing people's
social networks against them and
everything
and then the third is don't compromise
the long-term viability of your company
in exchange for short-term profits right
and so many companies have been through
this right yeah i mean and and uh and so
i think that's a way to think about it
and to think about it in light of what
the chinese commerce party leadership
wants right so what xi jinping talks
about
is a dual circulation economy right
where where they get a grip on critical
supply chains internationally i mean if
you want to look at human rights abuses
look at what they're doing in the drc in
the congo right uh in terms of
extracting at a horrible humanitarian
price the the rare earths that they need
uh to continue their their manufacturing
of of microelectronics for example um
and and but what he wants to do is get a
grip on those supply chains and then
create enough domestic demand that he
doesn't need
anybody else right right that he can
write the terms to everybody else that
he has everybody else you know uh in a
position that of of where he can use
coercive power and and what what i
describe in battlegrounds is the
strategy this is i think the the easy
way to think about it is co-option
coercion and concealment right co-opt
you co-opt businesses co-op deletes
right with the lure of short-term
profits and access to the chinese market
right you know
chinese investment
and then once you're in
right to use that that influence for
coercive purposes right look at what
they're doing to lithuania look what
they're doing to australia right look at
what they did to marriott mba at you
know
us and international companies um and
then and then and then to conceal all of
this oh this is just normal business
practices
well it's not normal business practices
right if you look at at one belt one
road right which is their they have
three main strategies right military
civil fusion and just gonna describe all
these in the book military civil fusion
then they then
you know associated with that is made in
china 2025 which is part of this dual
circulation economy becoming completely
no longer dependent at all on any
external sources of uh advanced
technologies for example or aspects of
supply chains
uh and then and then finally
one belt one road which is an effort to
create servile relationships with
companies by overly indebting them right
and so the new vanguard of the chinese
communist party you know
is is a chinese communist
party official accompanied by a chinese
national bank guy with a duffel bag full
of cash right and and they get the most
traction and corrupt governments you
know and then once they indebt them for
generations right then they can trade
debt for equity or they can use it for
course of purposes if you say one cross
word about the party where to call back
all your debt and you're gonna go broke
right so so i think
we just have to recognize co-option
coercion concealment
defend against it but then of course you
know as we look to the future how do we
how do we maintain and expand our
competitive advantages
you